mon cher Geoffroy cher Eric chers amis
tout d'abord je suis très émue et très
heureuse d'ouvrir ces états généraux et
je voulais à nouveau devant vous
remercier Éric Ciotti et ses équipes
pour l'organisation de cette journée
depuis ton élection tu n'as pas perdu de
temps tu as rassemblé tu as mobilisé tu
as fédéré et tu as travaillé alors
depuis ton élection et sous ton autorité
notre famille politique a renouer avec
les propositions et je voulais aussi
rendre un hommage particulier à
Christian Jacob qui est ici parmi nous
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
parce que chers Christian si nous sommes
tous là aujourd'hui rassemblés avec des
sensibilités parfois différentes des
parcours très différents les uns des
autres tu as permis et tu as pacifié ce
parti et moi je voulais remercier
d'ailleurs Xavier Bertrand Valérie
Pécresse François-Xavier Bellamy et tout
tous les autres que je vois pas d'ici
tous les élus parisiens ceux qui ont
porté aussi nos couleurs pour l'élection
présidentielle et toutes les échéances
qui sont venus c'est aussi grâce à toi
qu'on se retrouve encore aujourd'hui
rassemblée et aujourd'hui avec la digne
succession de Éric Ciotti encore merci à
toi Christian
[Applaudissements]
alors comme
l'exposé ce clip oui nous sommes là
on nous croit mort mais on nous appelle
toujours quand même
on nous croit mort mais on a toujours
besoin de nous pas comme un recours mais
comme un espoir et aujourd'hui on en a
fait des propositions sur la maîtrise
des flux migratoire
sur les retraites mais d'autres
propositions sont encore à venir sur
l'école on voit l'état de l'école
aujourd'hui où les inégalités sont
criantes ou la promotion l'ascension
sociale n'est plus possible par l'école
républicaine
nous aurons aussi d'autres propositions
sur le logement qui est à mon avis la
future bombe sociale aujourd'hui on nous
abordons une nouvelle étape une étape
importante pour notre famille politique
celle des États généraux et je voulais
remercier aussi Geoffroy Didier pour son
engagement parce que ces états généraux
seront coordonnées et suivis par lui
merci à toi Geoffroy d'avoir accepté
cette mission
nos travaux nos réflexions doivent
porter sur l'essentiel et l'essentiel
c'est quoi c'est d'affirmer à nos
concitoyens que la France a un avenir
les Français aujourd'hui s'interrogent
bien au-delà du pouvoir d'achat de la
maîtrise migratoire et d'autres sujets
il s'interroge c'est quoi la France
d'aujourd'hui
quelle sera la France de demain nous
sommes les héritiers des efforts de la
reconstruction à la naissance de la
Cinquième République tous ces acquis ont
été bradés où est la France qui a fait
le TGV où est la France dans la filière
nucléaire nous a assuré notre
indépendance où est la France de
l'innovation
où est la France qui avait mis fin au
bidonville pour construire des villes
nouvelles où est la France qui était
traversée par tant d'espérance par
l'envie du progrès pour tous
où est cette France qui était une
culture une manière de vivre ou la
liberté de chacun ne pouvait plus être
soumise à des croyances rétrogrades
notre France est un déclin face à cela
nous devons montrer aux Français qu'un
nouveau chemin est possible il nous faut
dire comment et à quoi on peut encore
servir la France pour le bonheur des
Français c'est cela l'enjeu que nous
sommes nous sommes collectivement fixés
et nos réponses seront tout le contraire
de la démographie démagogie qui est le
ferment de la guerre civile c'est cette
manière de répondre c'est ce qui nous
différenciera toujours des extrêmes
alors voilà ce qu'attend de nous nos
concitoyens
ils attendent de nous collectivement il
nous faut une manière de faire de la
politique où les ambitions personnelles
légitimes ça c'est pour tous ceux qui
sont ici et ceux qui ne sont pas ici
servent d'abord les intérêts collectifs
des Français nous attendons beaucoup de
ces états généraux
nous attendons beaucoup de toi cherche
Geoffroy nous attendons aussi beaucoup
du sens des responsabilités pour
l'essentiel de ceux qui sont au premier
rang de chacun d'entre nous merci encore
à toi Eric de m'avoir permis d'être là
où je peux être utile bon courage à toi
cher Geoffroy pour ces états généraux
merci
et merci à toi Rachida
[Applaudissements]